-Today is Friday.
And that's usually when I
catch up on some personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
return some e-mails,
and of course I send out
thank-you notes.
It's Friday. So, I was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was running a bit behind,
so I thought
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that okay with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate it.
James, can I get some thank-you-
note-writing music, please?
[ Wistful piano music playing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Piano music stops ]
-Wow.
-Is he real or animatronic?
-I think it was
animatronic James.
It's the one we got
from Chuck E. Cheese.
[ Laughter ]
-We got him at Chuck E. Cheese?
-At Chuck E. Cheese, yeah.
James couldn't make it today.
[ Laughter ]
[ Wistful piano music restarts ]
-Thank you, "F9" poster,
for looking like
the squad's facing
their most dangerous
threat yet --
gender reveal parties.
[ Laughter ]
[ Piano music stops, applause ]
[ Piano music restarts ]
Thank you, Milwaukee Bucks
mascot Bango,
for looking like one of the
reindeer who bullied Rudolph.
[ Piano music stops, laughter ]
"You'll never be able to --"
-[ High-pitched honk ]
"Rudolph!"
-"I don't want to be a dentist."
-"Hermey!
Bumbles bounce."
[ Piano music restarts ]
-Thank you, "Loki," for showing
that all it takes
to control a literal god
is a $39 shock collar
from chewy.com.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Chewy.
♪♪
-Thank you, 4th of July,
for being the day we celebrate
America's independence
and also try to convince our
dogs
that the world isn't ending.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Go in the basement or something.
"What is happening?"
-"You're going
to have to shoot him.
His back is broke."
[ Laughter ]
-What do you say, there,
Vice President?
-[ Laughing ] His back --
-"Well, then I...
took the revolver,
I put it in the dog's mouth."
-'Cause his back was --
-Looked him in the eye.
-He wasn't going to heal.
-Made sure he knew it was me
that was doing it.
-What does this have to do
with the punch line? Yeah.
-This is terrible.
[ Laughter ]
Not really a ha-ha joke.
That's a terrible joke.
♪♪
Thank you, sunscreen,
for not being called
"safety mayonnaise."
[ Laughter ]
"Honey, just put on
your safety mayonnaise.
You don't want the sun --"
♪♪
Thank you, bug zappers,
for letting me chill out
to the relaxing sounds
of mosquitos dying.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-[ Imitates zap ]
-[ Grumbles indistinctly ]
-"You killed me.
My family's in there."
[ Laughter ]
"Help me."
-Then a bee hops in there,
and it's like a good sizzle
for a couple minutes.
-Yeah, a couple hour--
-Let 'em fry. Let 'em fry.
-Then you shove a dog in there.
-And then, well,
dog's back was broken,
so we had to put the dog --
put the dog's face in there.
He still had
some life left to him.
-Mr. Vice President,
we got to get going.
-No, I'm almost finished
with the joke.
[ Laughter ]
That dog was still moving
a little bit, I think.
So we lit a fire to him
with gasoline.
[ Sniffs ]
[ Laughter ]
I was a little hungry.
I had just come from Popeye's,
not knowing what to order.
[ Laughter ]
"Mr. President, I'm just going
to turn your microphone off.
We've heard more than enough.
-The kids --
-We've heard more than enough.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
wearing socks and sandals,
for saying either I'm married,
or I will never be married.
[ Laughter ]
One or the other.
-One of the two.
-One or the other.
♪♪
-Dealer's choice.
-Thank you, hotel shampoos,
or as you're called after the
vacation is over, my shampoos.
[ Laughter and applause ]
No one's going to use them
anyway. Come on.
-Oh, may I take a few of those?
♪♪
-Thank you, QR codes,
for looking like barcodes
that got blackout drunk.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes.